el gobierno de la isla autorizó por
primera vez en casi seis décadas la
comercialización de carne de res y de
lácteos desde 1963 cuando el huracán
flora mató a su paso al 20% del ganado
del país la venta de carne de este
animal y de lácteos solo era permitida
con permisos de los castros durante 60
años nosotros no teníamos la oportunidad
de tener de o sea no teníamos derecho a
consumir un animal sin embargo siempre y
cuando yo cumpla con las regulaciones se
metan poniendo en este momento
proyectado por la cual debemos trabajar
es una oportunidad que no solamente
consume el productor sino consume su
familia y el resto de persona que lo
rodea en cuba solo pensar en las
consecuencias de vender carne de res
hacia muchos extreme hacerse los
ganaderos pueden ser multados por matar
a sus animales y existen condenas de
hasta 15 años de prisión para quienes
las roben la autorización de la venta de
la carne de res
a partir de que los productores cumplan
con los indicadores fundamentales de la
ganadería en cuanto a la producción el
incremento de la masa con la prohibición
iniciada en 1963 la producción de leche
aumentó hasta que en 1989 la unión
soviética colapsó desde entonces la
cantidad de ganado vacuno en el país se
ha mantenido a un 70 por ciento de los
niveles previos al paso del huracán
ahora se espera que la comercialización
ayude a aumentar la producción de carne
y lácteos en el país sin embargo si la
cantidad de animales disminuye
significativamente las prohibiciones
volverían a entrar en vigor con esta y
otras medidas el gobierno busca combatir
la escasez de comida que afecta incluso
a los alimentos básicos como el arroz o
las leguminosas